Witaj ponownie w Understanding Quantum Information and Computation. Nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM Quantum.
To jest 13. lekcja serii i pierwsza lekcja w czwartej i ostatniej jednostce, poświęconej kwantowej korekcji błędów.
Informatyka kwantowa ma potencjał do umożliwienia wydajnych rozwiązań zadań obliczeniowych, dla których
wydajne klasyczne algorytmy nie są znane i prawdopodobnie nie istnieją. Istnieją jednak bardzo poważne wyzwania, które
trzeba będzie pokonać, jeśli mamy zaimplementować tego rodzaju obliczenia kwantowe na dużą skalę, o których mamy nadzieję, że kiedyś będą
możliwe. Sedno sprawy jest takie, że informacja kwantowa jest niezwykle krucha. Można ją dosłownie zniszczyć samym
patrzeniem na nią. Aby działać poprawnie, komputery kwantowe muszą izolować przechowywane przez siebie informacje kwantowe
od otoczenia w ekstremalnym stopniu. Jednocześnie sam komputer kwantowy musi nam zapewnić
bardzo precyzyjną kontrolę nad tą informacją kwantową, co obejmuje właściwą inicjalizację, dokładne i niezawodne
operacje unitarne, a oczywiście możliwość wykonywania pomiarów, abyśmy mogli faktycznie uzyskać wyniki
obliczeń. Wyraźnie istnieje pewne napięcie między tymi wymaganiami i we wczesnych dniach informatyki kwantowej niektórzy postrzegali, że kruchość
informacji kwantowej i jej podatność zarówno na niedokładności, jak i szum środowiskowy ostatecznie
uczyni informatykę kwantową niemożliwą. Dziś nie ma wątpliwości, że zbudowanie dokładnego i niezawodnego
komputera kwantowego na dużą skalę jest ogromnym wyzwaniem, ale mamy kluczowe narzędzie, które nam w tym pomaga i które sprawia, że większość
ludzi znających dziedzinę jest optymistyczna co do tego, że informatyka kwantowa na dużą skalę stanie się kiedyś rzeczywistością. Tym narzędziem jest kwantowa korekcja błędów.
Przez następne cztery lekcje omówimy kwantową korekcję błędów ze skupieniem na
podstawach. W tej lekcji po raz pierwszy przyjrzymy się kwantowej korekcji błędów, w tym jednemu z pierwszych kwantowych
kodów korekcji błędów, jaki odkryto — 9-qubitowemu kodowi Shore'a — i omówimy też inny fundamentalny koncept w kwantowej
korekcji błędów znany jako dyskretyzacja błędów. W kolejnych lekcjach tej jednostki zobaczymy bardziej zaawansowane i ostatecznie lepsze
konstrukcje kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, a także omówimy problem kwantowych obliczeń na zakodowanej informacji kwantowej przy użyciu
komponentów obliczeniowych, które same nie są doskonałe i są podatne na błędy. Oto krótki przegląd
lekcji. Zaczniemy od omówienia klasycznych kodów repetycyjnych, które są być może najprostszym i najbardziej podstawowym typem
klasycznego kodu korekcji błędów. Klasyczne kody repetycyjne nie są szczególnie dobrymi kodami według klasycznych standardów
teorii kodowania — przynajmniej nie samodzielnie. Ale to jest w porządku — tutaj idziemy na prostotę. W szczególności
przyjrzymy się niemal najprostszemu klasycznemu kodowi korekcji błędów, jaki można sobie wyobrazić, który następnie użyjemy jako podstawę dla prostego przykładu
kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów. Tym przykładem jest 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a, który omówimy szczegółowo,
w tym opis samego kodu, a także procedury kodowania qubitów za pomocą tego kodu, wykrywania błędów na zakodowanych qubitach i
korygowania tych błędów. W trzeciej części lekcji omówimy dyskretyzację błędów, która pozwala nam myśleć o dowolnych błędach na
qubitach — które w zasadzie tworzą kontinuum możliwości — w dyskretnych kategoriach, sprowadzając błędy w zasadzie do
tzw. przerzuceń bitów i przerzuceń fazy. Zanim przejdziemy do technicznych szczegółów kwantowej korekcji błędów, warto
poświęcić chwilę na rozważenie potrzeby kwantowej korekcji błędów, a także klasycznej korekcji
błędów. Jak sugerowałem na początku lekcji, komputery kwantowe są wysoce podatne na błędy ze względu na kruchość
informacji kwantowej. W szczególności niechciane interakcje ze środowiskiem — czyli innymi słowy
resztą świata — mogą zakłócać informację kwantową. Te niechciane interakcje mogą powodować dekoherencję, gdzie informacja
zasadniczo wycieka do środowiska, powodując, że informacja przechowywana przez komputer kwantowy zachowuje się coraz bardziej
klasycznie. Krytycznie ważne jest też rozpoznanie, że operacje kwantowe mogą być wykonywane tylko z ograniczoną
dokładnością. Na przykład możemy chcieć wykonać konkretną bramkę kwantową na qubicie, ale ponieważ fizyczne urządzenia nie są
nigdy doskonałe, to, co faktycznie implementujemy, może być tylko przybliżeniem tej bramki. Może to nie być wielki problem przy
jednej bramce, ale jeśli naszym zamiarem jest wykonanie tysięcy lub milionów bramek kwantowych, te małe niedokładności zaczną
się kumulować i gdy obliczenia się zakończą, możemy skończyć z bardzo różnym stanem od tego, czego
oczekiwaliśmy. Jest to więc zupełnie inny rodzaj błędów, ale z pewnością taki, którego nie możemy
ignorować. Ludzie studiują klasyczne kody korekcji błędów od prawie stulecia i kody te mają wiele zastosowań, w tym w
transmisji i przechowywaniu informacji. Ale ponieważ klasyczne komponenty obliczeniowe są tak niezawodne, faktycznie nie
potrzebujemy korekcji błędów do budowania klasycznych komputerów. Może jednak korekcja błędów faktycznie nie jest potrzebna
do budowania niezawodnych komputerów kwantowych na dużą skalę. Na przykład główna idea kwantowych obliczeń
topologicznych polega na tym, że może być możliwe zbudowanie odpornych układów kwantowych, które są z natury chronione przed szumem ze względu na
topologiczne właściwości układów. Ale nie wiemy, czy to będzie możliwe i jest dość powszechne przekonanie,
że korekcja błędów będzie prawdopodobnie niezbędna w takiej czy innej formie dla obliczeń kwantowych na dużą skalę. Teraz omówimy klasyczne
kody repetycyjne, które stanowią podstawę dla naszego pierwszego kwantowego kodu korekcji błędów — 9-qubitowego kodu Shore'a,
który zobaczymy za chwilę. Kody repetycyjne to bardzo podstawowe przykłady kodów korekcji błędów.
Idea polega na tym, że możemy chronić bity przed błędami przez proste powtarzanie każdego bitu pewną liczbę razy. W szczególności przyjrzyjmy się
3-bitowemu kodowi repetycyjnemu. Tutaj kodujemy jeden bit w trzy, po prostu powtarzając bit trzy razy:
zero jest kodowane jako 000, a jeden jest kodowany jako 111. Oczywiście jeśli nic nie pójdzie nie tak, możemy
łatwo rozróżnić dwie możliwości. Ale jeśli wystąpił błąd i jeden z bitów się przerzucił — powiedzmy,
że zero zmienia się w jeden lub jeden w zero — to możemy wciąż ustalić, co było oryginalnym bitem,
widząc, która z dwóch wartości binarnych pojawia się dwukrotnie. Równoważnie możemy dekodować, obliczając wartość większościową —
czyli wartość binarną pojawiającą się najczęściej. Nie trudno zobaczyć, że
jeśli mamy co najwyżej jeden błąd przerzucenia bitu, dekodowanie będzie poprawne. Oczywiście jeśli dwa bity się przerzucą lub
wszystkie trzy, to nie zadziała i dostaniemy błędną wartość przy dekodowaniu. To jest ogólna właściwość,
którą posiada każdy kod korekcji błędów — możesz być w stanie skorygować pewne błędy, ale nigdy nie będziesz w stanie skorygować każdego błędu. Ostatecznie chodzi
o zmniejszanie szansy na błąd, a nie o gwarantowanie poprawności, co generalnie nie jest
możliwe. Jako przykład sytuacji, w której możemy zmniejszyć szansę na błąd, załóżmy, że naszym
celem jest przekazanie jednego bitu hipotetycznemu odbiorcy i w tym celu możemy transmitować bity przez
tzw. binarny symetryczny kanał, który przerzuca każdy bit przez niego wysyłany niezależnie z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem
P. Więc z prawdopodobieństwem 1 minus P odbiorca otrzyma bit, który zamierzaliśmy wysłać, ale z prawdopodobieństwem P
bit się przerzuca i odbiorca otrzymuje wartość przeciwną do tego, co wysłaliśmy. Jeśli nie używamy kodu repetycyjnego
i zamiast tego po prostu wysyłamy nasz bit przez kanał, odbiorca otrzyma błędny bit z
prawdopodobieństwem P. Z drugiej strony, jeśli najpierw zakodujemy bit za pomocą 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego i
następnie wyślemy każdy z trzech bitów kodowania przez kanał, to każdy z nich przerzuca się z prawdopodobieństwem P, więc
szanse na przerzucenie bitu są teraz większe, bo teraz są trzy bity, które mogą się potencjalnie przerzucić, a nie jeden.
Ale jeśli co najwyżej jeden z bitów się przerzuci, odbiorca będzie mógł poprawnie zdekodować — dostaniemy błąd po
dekodowaniu tylko wtedy, gdy dwa lub więcej bitów przerzuci się podczas transmisji. Nie trudno obliczyć, że dzieje się to z
prawdopodobieństwem 3P² - 2P³. Dla wartości P mniejszych niż 1/12
prowadzi to do zmniejszenia prawdopodobieństwa, że odbiorca skończy z błędnym bitem. Wciąż będzie szansa na błąd w tym przypadku, ale
kod zmniejsza jej prawdopodobieństwo. Jeśli chciałbyś/chciałabyś jeszcze bardziej zmniejszyć tę szansę, mógłbyś/mogłabyś zrobić to za pomocą
innego kodu, w tym między innymi możliwości użycia kodu repetycyjnego, gdzie zakodowany bit jest powtarzany
więcej niż trzy razy. Dla wartości P większych niż 1/12, przy okazji, kod faktycznie
pogarsza sytuację w sensie zwiększania prawdopodobieństwa, że odbiorca otrzyma błędny bit — więc z pewnością nie używalibyśmy tego kodu w tej
sytuacji. 3-bitowy kod repetycyjny jest klasycznym kodem korekcji błędów, ale możemy też rozważyć, co się stanie, jeśli spróbujemy
użyć go do ochrony qubitów przed błędami. Nie jest to zbyt dobry kwantowy kod korekcji błędów — jak zobaczymy, może
korygować niektóre błędy, ale sprawia, że inne błędy są bardziej prawdopodobne. Jest jednak pierwszym krokiem w kierunku kodu Shore'a,
więc zobaczmy, jak działa dla qubitów. Przede wszystkim, żeby być precyzyjnym — gdy mówimy o 3-bitowym kodzie repetycyjnym używanym
dla qubitów, mamy na myśli kodowanie qubitu, jak pokazano na ekranie, gdzie alpha|0⟩ plus beta|1⟩ jest
zakodowane jako alpha|000⟩ plus beta|111⟩ — czyli standardowy stan bazowy jest powtarzany trzy razy.
Zauważ w szczególności, że nie jest to to samo, co trzykrotne powtórzenie stanu kwantowego — czyli stan kwantowy s
zakodowany jako s ⊗ s ⊗ s — co nie jest kodowaniem, które bylibyśmy w stanie
zaimplementować dla nieznanego stanu kwantowego s ze względu na twierdzenie o nieklonowalności. Omawiane kodowanie,
natomiast, jest bardzo łatwo implementowalne. Oto bardzo prosty circuit kwantowy, który to robi — używa dwóch zainicjalizowanych roboczych qubitów i dwóch
bramek kontrolowanego-NOT. Załóżmy teraz, że po wykonaniu kodowania
nastąpił błąd i w szczególności załóżmy, że operacja Pauli-X — czyli przerzucenie bitu — zaszła na jednym z
qubitów — na rysunku jest to środkowy qubit. Oczywiście nie jest to jedyny rodzaj błędu, który mógłby wystąpić i możesz
sprzeciwić się idei, że błąd przyjmuje formę tej doskonałej operacji unitarnej, ale wrócimy do tego później w lekcji. Na razie możemy
po prostu traktować to jako przykład. Oto wynikowy stan — jest taki sam jak oryginalne kodowanie z tym wyjątkiem,
że środkowy bit w każdym ket jest przerzucony. Oczywiście widzimy to z matematycznych wyrażeń dla stanu.
Ale załóżmy, że mamy tylko trzy qubity i podejrzewamy, że mogło dojść do przerzucenia bitu, ale nie wiemy, który qubit mógłby zostać
dotknięty. Jednym sposobem na ustalenie, czy doszło do przerzucenia bitu, byłoby wykonanie pomiaru w standardowej bazie i zbadanie wyniku. W tym przypadku zobaczylibyśmy
albo |010⟩ albo |101⟩ z prawdopodobieństwami zależącymi od alpha i beta i w obu przypadkach nasz wniosek
byłby taki, że środkowy bit się przerzucił. Ale niestety to niszczy oryginalny stan kwantowy i ten stan
może być dla nas cenny — bo cały punkt to ochrona tego stanu kwantowego. Więc to nie jest dobra
opcja. Zamiast tego możemy użyć circuit kwantowego pokazanego tutaj na ekranie, gdzie podajemy zakodowany stan
do górnych trzech qubitów. Zasadniczo circuit oblicza parzystość stanów standardowej bazy
dla górnych dwóch qubitów, a także dla dolnych dwóch qubitów kodowania — i to ujawni
lokalizację przerzucenia bitu. W szczególności w tym przypadku dostaniemy wynik jeden dla obu tych kontroli parzystości i z
tych informacji możemy wywnioskować, że to środkowy bit różni się od pozostałych dwóch — a więc ewidentnie to ten się
przerzucił. I co kluczowe, nie powoduje to zapaści stanu, więc mamy teraz szansę spróbować skorygować to przerzucenie
bitu, abyśmy mogli ostatecznie zdekodować i odzyskać nasz oryginalny stan. Wrócimy do korekcji
za chwilę, ale najpierw rozważmy krótko inne możliwości błędu przerzucenia bitu. Jeśli zamiast tego błąd przerzucenia bitu
zaszedł na dolnym lub lewym qubicie, dostalibyśmy wynik jeden-zero czytając od dołu do góry i znowu
stan nie zmieniłby się. A jeśli przerzucenie bitu dotknęło górny qubit, wynik byłby
zero-jeden, i ponownie stan się nie zmienia. A przy okazji, jeśli
w ogóle nie było błędu przerzucenia bitu, wynik pomiaru to zero-zero i ponownie stan wychodzi niezmieniony.
Podsumujmy to w formie tabeli, gdzie wymieniamy każdy z możliwych stanów, które uzyskujemy z co najwyżej jednym przerzuceniem bitu, wyniki
pomiaru — które w kontekście korekcji błędów nazywamy syndromem — i korektę, którą musimy wprowadzić, aby odzyskać oryginalne
kodowanie. Jeśli nie było błędu, syndrom to zero-zero i nic nie trzeba robić, żeby naprawić
stan. Jeśli dolny lub skrajny lewy qubit doświadczył przerzucenia bitu, syndrom to jeden-zero i odpowiednia korekcja
to zastosowanie bramki X do dolnego lub skrajnego lewego qubitu. Pozostałe dwa przypadki są
podobne. Jeśli więc zastosujemy odpowiednią korekcję na podstawie syndromu, na pewno odzyskamy oryginalne
kodowanie we wszystkich czterech przypadkach. Jeszcze raz — rozważamy tylko możliwość, że wystąpił co najwyżej jeden błąd
przerzucenia bitu. To nie zadziałałoby poprawnie, gdyby dwa lub trzy bity się przerzuciły i nie rozważaliśmy też
możliwości innych błędów. Rozważmy teraz inny typ błędu w kwantowym kontekście. Błędy przerzucenia bitu
nie są jedynymi błędami, o których musimy się martwić. Musimy się na przykład martwić też o błędy przerzucenia fazy,
zwane po prostu przerzuceniami fazy, które są opisywane przez bramki Z — czyli równoważnie Pauli-Z.
Niestety 3-bitowy kod repetycyjny zupełnie nie wykrywa przerzuceń fazy. Na przykład, załóżmy, że
kodujemy qubit za pomocą 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, jak poprzednio, i błąd przerzucenia fazy zachodzi na środkowym
qubicie. Otrzymamy stan pokazany na ekranie, który jest dokładnie kodowaniem, które dostalibyśmy, gdyby przerzucenie
fazy nastąpiło na oryginalnym qubicie przed zakodowaniem. Więc jeśli wykonamy ten sam
circuit co poprzednio, żeby spróbować wykryć błąd, dostaniemy syndrom zero-zero, co błędnie sugeruje, że nie wystąpiły żadne błędy.
3-bitowy kod repetycyjny działa więc przy co najwyżej jednym błędzie przerzucenia bitu, ale nie wykrywa błędów przerzucenia fazy.
W rzeczywistości pogarsza sytuację w pewnym sensie, bo teraz mamy trzy razy więcej qubitów, które potencjalnie mogą doświadczyć błędów przerzucenia
fazy. Zaobserwowaliśmy, że 3-bitowy kod repetycyjny jest całkowicie nieświadomy błędów przerzucenia fazy — więc nie wydaje się
zbyt pomocny w radzeniu sobie z tym rodzajem błędu. Ale w rzeczywistości możemy zmodyfikować 3-bitowy kod repetycyjny tak, żeby
wykrywał błędy przerzucenia fazy i wyjaśnię teraz, jak to można zrobić. Oto oryginalny circuit do
kodowania qubitu za pomocą 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego i sposób jego modyfikacji jest bardzo prosty — po prostu stosujemy bramkę
Hadamard do każdego qubitu kodowania. Bramka Hadamard przekształca stan zero w stan plus, a stan jeden
w stan minus. Wynikowym efektem netto jest uzyskanie stanu pokazanego na ekranie, gdzie |+++⟩
i |---⟩ to skrócona notacja dla tensora trzech stanów plus lub trzech stanów minus.
Błąd przerzucenia fazy — czyli bramka Z — przekształca stany plus w stany minus i stany minus w stany plus,
więc to kodowanie będzie użyteczne do wykrywania i korygowania błędów przerzucenia fazy. Aby to zrobić, możemy
zmodyfikować circuit wykrywania błędów jak poprzednio w następujący sposób. Oto circuit od poprzednio i co zrobimy, to
po prostu umieszczamy bramki Hadamard zarówno na początku, jak i na końcu, jak pokazano na ekranie.
Idea jest bardzo prosta. Pierwsze trzy bramki Hadamard przekształcają stany plus i minus z powrotem na stany zero i jeden.
Takie same kontrole parzystości jak poprzednio zachodzą, a następnie druga warstwa bramek Hadamard przenosi nas z powrotem do naszego
kodowania. Innym sposobem myślenia o tym jest to, że w zasadzie po prostu przekształcamy błędy przerzucenia fazy w błędy przerzucenia bitu przez sprzężenie operacjami Hadamard.
Możemy przy okazji uprościć circuit trochę — ten circuit tutaj jest całkowicie równoważny
i możesz to sprawdzić samodzielnie, jeśli masz ochotę. Jeśli więc podamy nasz zakodowany qubit do tego circuit przy założeniu,
że nie wystąpiły żadne błędy przerzucenia fazy, otrzymamy syndrom 0-0, wskazujący, że nie było błędów przerzucenia
fazy. A jeśli mamy błąd przerzucenia fazy na górnym qubicie — powiedzmy — to skrajne prawe plusy i minusy się przerzucają
i powoduje to inny syndrom błędu 0-1. W tym przypadku identyfikuje to lokalizację przerzucenia fazy, tak jak
mieliśmy dla przerzucenia bitu, i możemy to skorygować przez zastosowanie bramki Z do górnego qubitu. Sytuacja
jest podobna dla błędów przerzucenia fazy na którymkolwiek z pozostałych dwóch qubitów. Możemy więc faktycznie wykryć i
korygować do jednego błędu przerzucenia fazy za pomocą tego kodu. Ale niestety, jak można się domyślić, nie możemy już
korygować błędów przerzucenia bitu. Nie wszystko stracone jednak, bo w rzeczywistości możemy połączyć te dwa kody
razem, żeby uzyskać kod, który może korygować zarówno błędy przerzucenia bitu, jak i błędy przerzucenia fazy — i w rzeczywistości będzie
mógł korygować dowolny błąd na jednym qubicie. Czas teraz omówić 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a — kwantowy
kod korekcji błędów, który uzyskujemy przez połączenie dwóch kodów, które właśnie widzieliśmy — czyli 3-bitowego
kodu repetycyjnego, który pozwala nam korygować jeden błąd przerzucenia bitu, i zmodyfikowanej wersji tego kodu, która pozwala nam korygować jeden błąd przerzucenia
fazy. Mówiąc dokładniej, 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a to kod uzyskany przez konkatenację dwóch kodów, co oznacza,
że najpierw stosujemy jedno kodowanie — które koduje jeden qubit w trzy — a następnie stosujemy drugie kodowanie do każdego z
trzech qubitów oddzielnie. Dostaniemy więc dziewięć qubitów w sumie. Możemy to wyrazić w formie
diagramu circuit w następujący sposób. Najpierw stosujemy zmodyfikowaną wersję 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego,
który wykrywa błędy przerzucenia fazy, a następnie kodujemy każdy z wynikowych qubitów niezależnie za pomocą oryginalnego
3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego. Jeśli więc trochę zmniejszymy ten circuit, żeby zrobić więcej miejsca, możemy
opisać kod nieco innymi słowami, opisując, jak dwa standardowe stany bazowe dla naszego oryginalnego qubitu są
kodowane. Gdy to wiemy, możemy określić przez liniowość, jak dowolny wektor stanu qubitu jest
kodowany. To jest więc 9-qubitowy kod Shore'a i idea jest taka, że jeden z kodów pozwala nam korygować błędy przerzucenia
fazy, a drugi pozwala nam korygować błędy przerzucenia bitu — i jak zobaczymy, będzie to faktycznie oznaczać, że możemy
korygować dowolny błąd na jednym qubicie. Teraz zobaczmy, jak możemy wykrywać i korygować błędy za pomocą 9-qubitowego
kodu Shore'a, zaczynając od błędów przerzucenia bitu, zwanych też błędami X. Oto circuit, który wykonuje
kodowanie i żeby ułatwić omówienie, będziemy myśleć o dziewięciu qubitach, które dostajemy z tego kodu, jako
pogrupowanych w trzy bloki po trzy qubity, gdzie każdy blok reprezentuje kodowanie, które dostajemy przez zastosowanie
drugiego kroku kodowania — czyli zwykłego 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego. Ten jest zwany kodem wewnętrznym w
tym kontekście, podczas gdy kod zewnętrzny to kod używany do pierwszego kroku kodowania, który w tym przypadku jest zmodyfikowaną
wersją 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, działającą dla błędów przerzucenia fazy. Aby korygować błędy przerzucenia bitu, możemy
po prostu traktować każdy z bloków oddzielnie. Każdy blok to kodowanie qubitu za pomocą 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego
i ten kod chroni przed błędami przerzucenia bitu. Załóżmy najpierw, że błąd X zachodzi na którymkolwiek z qubitów —
na przykład na środkowym qubicie w środkowym bloku. Jeśli niezależnie sprawdzamy każdy z bloków pod kątem błędów przerzucenia bitu i
korygujemy wszelkie znalezione błędy, ten błąd zostanie skorygowany i oryginalne kodowanie zostanie
odzyskane. W rzeczywistości moglibyśmy mieć nawet wiele błędów X i wciąż je korygować w ten sposób, pod warunkiem, że błędy są
w oddzielnych blokach. Gdybyśmy mieli dwa lub trzy błędy X w jednym bloku, bylibyśmy w tarapatach, ale
dopóki jest co najwyżej jeden błąd X na blok, kod wewnętrzny je złapie i będziemy w stanie odzyskać oryginalny zakodowany
stan. Korygowanie błędów przerzucenia bitu jest więc dość prostą sprawą dla tego kodu. Musimy też rozważyć błędy przerzucenia
fazy — czyli błędy Z. Tym razem nie jest tak jasne, co powinniśmy zrobić, bo kod zewnętrzny jest tym,
który koryguje błędy przerzucenia fazy, ale nie możemy bezpośrednio wykrywać i korygować ich, bo kod wewnętrzny jakoś
jest na przeszkodzie. Ale za chwilę zobaczymy, jak to zrobić. Żeby lepiej zrozumieć, jak błędy X i Z
działają i jakie efekty wywierają w circuit kwantowych, pomocne jest zaobserwowanie kilku prostych relacji między tymi błędami a bramkami
CNOT — co będzie też pomocne w późniejszej lekcji. Zacznijmy od błędów X,
czyli bramek X, i tego, jak odnoszą się do bramek CNOT. Jeśli zastosujemy bramkę X do
docelowego qubitu bramki CNOT i następnie zastosujemy CNOT, to jest równoważne zamianie kolejności i wykonaniu CNOT
najpierw. Z drugiej strony, jeśli zastosujemy bramkę X do kontrolnego qubitu bramki CNOT i następnie zastosujemy CNOT, nie możemy po prostu
zamienić kolejności, ale zamiast tego musimy zastosować bramkę X do obu qubitów. Możesz sprawdzić wszystkie te relacje samodzielnie,
jeśli chcesz, myśląc o tym, co się dzieje z standardowymi stanami bazowymi. Sytuacja jest podobna dla błędów Z,
z tym że role kontrolnego i docelowego qubitu się zamieniają. W szczególności, jeśli wykonamy bramkę
Z na kontrolnym qubicie bramki CNOT i następnie wykonamy CNOT, to ma taki sam efekt jak wykonanie
bramki Z po CNOT. Ale jeśli zamiast tego wykonamy bramkę Z na docelowym qubicie, to jest
równoważne najpierw wykonaniu CNOT, a następnie zastosowaniu bramki Z do obu qubitów. I wreszcie wszystkie te
relacje są symetryczne w sensie, że zawsze możemy zamienić kolejność bramek po obu stronach każdego równania —
co jest równoważne wzięciu odwrotności lub sprzężonej transpozycji obu stron, biorąc pod uwagę, że bramki X, Z i CNOT
są wszystkie swoimi własnymi odwrotnościami. Rozważmy teraz błędy przerzucenia fazy i jak możemy je wykrywać i korygować
za pomocą 9-qubitowego kodu Shore'a. Oto nasz circuit kodowania i będziemy nadal myśleć o dziewięciu
qubitach używanych w kodowaniu jako pogrupowanych w trzy bloki po trzy qubity. Załóżmy, że błąd Z zachodzi na
którymkolwiek z qubitów, na przykład tym zaznaczonym tutaj. Używając tego, co właśnie zaobserwowaliśmy o bramkach Z
i bramkach CNOT, jest to równoważne dwóm błędom Z przed bramką CNOT — jednym na
kontrolnym i jednym na docelowym qubicie. Te błędy akurat komutują z innym CNOT w bloku, więc możemy
zamienić kolejność i oto co dostajemy. Dolny błąd Z nic nie robi, bo działa na stan zero,
i możemy przesunąć wszystko inne i uzyskać ten diagram. To co odkryliśmy, to że błąd Z gdzieś w
środkowym bloku jest równoważny błędowi Z zachodzącemu na środkowym qubicie przed drugą fazą kodowania.
Możesz rozumować dokładnie tak samo dla błędu Z na którymkolwiek z qubitów. Przerzucenie fazy na którymkolwiek qubicie w bloku
jest równoważne przerzuceniu fazy na odpowiadającym qubicie przed kodowaniem wewnętrznym — i to jest dość proste i intuicyjne, jeśli
pomyślisz, jak błędy Z wpływają na 3-bitowy kod repetycyjny. Jedną opcją dla radzenia sobie z błędem Z
jest zdekodowanie kodu wewnętrznego, a następnie wykrycie i skorygowanie błędów Z za pomocą kodu zewnętrznego — zmodyfikowanej
wersji 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego, który może korygować błąd Z. To koryguje nasz błąd Z i
moglibyśmy ponownie zakodować za pomocą kodu wewnętrznego, gdybyśmy chcieli. Możemy też korygować błędy Z
„w miejscu" — że tak powiem — bez dekodowania i ponownego kodowania. I to jest dość proste, ale żeby wyjaśnić, jak
możemy to zrobić, będziemy potrzebować trochę więcej miejsca. Załóżmy, że dekodujemy kod wewnętrzny
i następnie obliczamy syndrom dla kodu zewnętrznego za pomocą tej samej metody co poprzednio, angażując tylko trzy qubity z kodu zewnętrznego,
i następnie ponownie kodujemy. Możemy uprościć wszystkie te CNOT-y trochę — i w rzeczywistości
możemy użyć relacji między bramkami NOT i bramkami CNOT, które właśnie zaobserwowaliśmy chwilę temu, żeby w tym pomóc.
Przez to możemy zaoszczędzić cztery CNOT-y i oto circuit, który uzyskujemy. Jeśli błąd Z zaszedł na jednym
z qubitów, to co syndrom nam teraz mówi, to nie który qubit doświadczył błędu Z, ale w którym bloku błąd Z
się zdarzył. Ale to jest w porządku, bo wiemy, że nie ma znaczenia, który qubit w bloku doświadczy błędu Z — efekt
jest taki sam dla wszystkich trzech qubitów w tym bloku. Możemy więc faktycznie skorygować błąd Z przez zastosowanie bramki Z do któregokolwiek z
qubitów w tym bloku. Przy okazji jest to przykład tego, co się nazywa degeneracją w kodzie
korekcji błędów, gdzie nie identyfikujemy jednoznacznie danego błędu, ale jesteśmy w stanie go skorygować. Na koniec załóżmy, że zarówno błąd
przerzucenia bitu, jak i błąd przerzucenia fazy zachodzą — ewentualnie na tym samym qubicie. Na przykład załóżmy, że
błąd przerzucenia bitu i błąd przerzucenia fazy zachodzą na tym konkretnym qubicie. Jak się okazuje, te błędy mogą być
wykrywane i korygowane całkowicie niezależnie. I w rzeczywistości nie ma znaczenia, czy korygujemy każdy blok pod kątem błędu
przerzucenia bitu najpierw, a następnie korygujemy pod kątem przerzuceń fazy, czy robimy to na odwrót. Żeby to zobaczyć, najpierw zaobserwujmy,
że kolejność tych błędów nie ma znaczenia, więc możemy je zamienić, jeśli chcemy. Powodem jest nie to, że X i Z komutują,
bo nie komutują — X * Z = -Z * X — ale czynnik -1 nie ma znaczenia w tej sytuacji, bo jest to faza globalna. Możemy teraz przesunąć błąd Z tak jak
poprzednio i w tym momencie jest oczywiste, że gdybyśmy najpierw skorygowali każdy blok dla błędów X, a następnie skorygowali
błędy Z, to byśmy skorygowali oba błędy. Ewentualnie, z jakiegoś powodu,
gdybyśmy postanowili najpierw korygować błędy Z, moglibyśmy to zrobić i błąd X absolutnie nie ma wpływu na ten proces.
To musi być prawdą, ponieważ po pierwsze: błąd X komutuje z każdą bramką w circuit, który oblicza syndrom
dla kodu zewnętrznego. I po drugie: kolejność między błędem X a bramką Z, którą stosujemy, żeby dokonać
korekcji, nie ma znaczenia — tak jak argumentowaliśmy, gdy bramka Z była błędem. To pozwala na korekcję błędu Z
i możemy następnie skorygować każdy blok, aby wyeliminować błąd X. Twierdziliśmy więc, że możemy
korygować błąd X, błąd Z lub oba na którymkolwiek z qubitów za pomocą tego kodu.
W rzeczywistości możemy korygować więcej błędów niż to — na przykład wiele błędów X, pod warunkiem, że wpadają do różnych bloków,
lub wiele błędów Z, pod warunkiem, że co najwyżej jeden blok dostaje nieparzystą ich liczbę. Ale idąc naprzód, najbardziej istotne
będzie to, że możemy korygować błąd X, błąd Z lub oba na jednym qubicie. I w ostatniej części lekcji
zobaczymy, jak to jest w rzeczywistości wystarczające do stwierdzenia, że ten kod może korygować dowolny błąd na jakimkolwiek jednym
qubicie. Zanim przejdziemy do ostatniej części lekcji, w której rozważymy dowolne błędy kwantowe, krótko
rozważymy wydajność N-qubitowego kodu Shore'a, gdy błędy reprezentowane przez macierze Pauliego zachodzą losowo na
qubitach. Mówiąc konkretniej, rozważmy prosty model szumu, gdzie błędy zachodzą niezależnie na qubitach,
z każdym qubitem doświadczającym błędu z prawdopodobieństwem P i bez korelacji między błędami na różnych
qubitach. Najgorszy przypadek dla 9-qubitowego kodu Shore'a to taki, że błąd Y — czyli zarówno błąd X, jak i Z —
zachodzi na każdym dotkniętym qubicie i założymy ten najgorszy przypadek po prostu dla uzyskania ograniczenia
na wydajność kodu. Ale możesz też rozważyć na przykład, że trzy błędy Pauliego są równie
prawdopodobne. Załóżmy teraz, że Q jest qubitem w pewnym konkretnym stanie, który chcemy chronić przed błędami. Wyobraź sobie, że
mamy możliwość użycia 9-qubitowego kodu Shore'a — czy powinniśmy go użyć? Odpowiedź niekoniecznie
brzmi tak, ponieważ jeśli jest zbyt dużo szumu — czyli P jest zbyt duże — użycie kodu Shore'a może faktycznie pogorszyć sytuację,
tak jak mieliśmy dla kodu repetycyjnego, gdy P jest większe niż 1/2. Ale jeśli P jest wystarczająco małe, to
odpowiedź brzmi tak — powinniśmy użyć kodu. Zobaczmy więc, dlaczego tak jest i co to znaczy, że P jest zbyt duże lub wystarczająco małe
dla tego kodu. Kod Shore'a może korygować dowolny błąd Pauliego na pojedynczym qubicie i w najgorszym
przypadku, gdzie błędy Pauliego to błędy Y, oznacza to, że kod pomyślnie chroni Q z prawdopodobieństwem podanym przez
wyrażenie pokazane na ekranie. Konkretnie kod działa, gdy nie ma żadnych błędów — co zachodzi
z prawdopodobieństwem (1-P)⁹, bo musi być dziewięć qubitów, z których każdy jest nienaruszony — i działa, gdy jest
dokładnie jeden błąd. Biorąc pod uwagę, że jest dziewięć różnych qubitów, które mogą zostać dotknięte, zachodzi to z prawdopodobieństwem 9P(1-P)⁸.
Z drugiej strony, jeśli nie trudzilibyśmy się użyciem kodu, nasz jedyny qubit byłby nienaruszony przez błąd z
prawdopodobieństwem 1-P. Kod pomaga więc tylko wtedy, gdy pierwsze prawdopodobieństwo jest większe niż drugie,
ponieważ te wyrażenia reprezentują nasze prawdopodobieństwa sukcesu w dwóch przypadkach — gdy używamy kodu i gdy
go nie używamy. Oto wykres tych dwóch funkcji dla małych wartości P. Stwierdzamy, że punkt równowagi zachodzi w
okolicach 3 i 3/4 procent. Więc jeśli P jest mniejsze niż ta wartość, kod
pomaga. W punkcie równowagi prawdopodobieństwa są równe, więc po prostu marnujemy czas i 8 qubitów, jeśli
używamy kodu, ale poza tym nie ma żadnej szkody. I po przekroczeniu tego punktu zdecydowanie nie powinniśmy używać tego kodu,
bo faktycznie zwiększa on szansę na błąd na zakodowanym qubicie, który zwykle w tym kontekście nazywamy
logicznym qubitem. I dzieje się to po prostu dlatego, że szansa na dwa lub więcej błędów na dziewięciu qubitach jest
większa niż szansa na jeden błąd na jednym qubicie dla wartości P w tym zakresie. 3 i 3/4 procent może się nie wydawać zbyt
dobre, szczególnie w porównaniu z 50%, które jest analogicznym punktem równowagi dla 3-bitowego kodu repetycyjnego dla
informacji klasycznej. Ale trudniej jest chronić informację kwantową, i co więcej, chociaż ten
kod reprezentuje błyskotliwe odkrycie jako pierwszy kwantowy kod korekcji błędów i jest świetny do celów pedagogicznych, faktem jest,
że to po prostu nie jest szczególnie dobry kod w praktycznych kategoriach. Rozważaliśmy do tej pory błędy X
i Z w kontekście 9-qubitowego kodu Shore'a. Rozważmy teraz dowolne błędy,
zaczynając od unitarnych błędów. Takim błędem mógłby być na przykład bardzo mały
obrót sfery Blocha — prawdopodobnie reprezentujący błąd poniesiony przez bramkę, która nie jest doskonała — lub
mogłoby to być dowolna inna operacja unitarna na qubicie, niekoniecznie coś bliskiego operacji
identyczności. Może się wydawać, że korygowanie takich błędów jest trudne — istnieje nieskończenie wiele możliwych błędów takich
jak te i nie do pomyślenia jest, żebyśmy mogli jakoś dokładnie zidentyfikować, czym błąd jest, a następnie go cofnąć. Ale nie
musimy robić czegokolwiek innego niż to, co już omówiliśmy. Dopóki możemy korygować przerzucenie bitu, przerzucenie fazy lub oba, to faktycznie
uda nam się skorygować dowolny jednoqUbitowy unitarny błąd. Wyjaśnię teraz, dlaczego.
Przede wszystkim, jak wszystkie macierze 2×2, możemy wyrazić dowolną unitarną macierz
reprezentującą błąd na pojedynczym qubicie jako kombinację liniową czterech macierzy Pauliego, włączając macierz
identyczności. Przy okazji, jak mogłeś/mogłaś zauważyć, używam wielkich liter X, Y i Z do oznaczania nieidentycznościowych macierzy Pauliego
i będę to kontynuować przez resztę tej serii. To jest konwencjonalne w kwantowej korekcji błędów i też sprawia, że
rzeczy są trochę łatwiejsze do czytania w tym kontekście. Wygodne będzie też używanie indeksów dolnych, aby wskazać, który
qubit dana jednoqUbitowa operacja unitarna działa na. Jeśli na przykład używamy konwencji numerowania qubitów Qiskit,
zaczynając od qubitu zero po prawej, to mamy wyrażenia pokazane na ekranie dla różnych operacji unitarnych na pojedynczych qubitach,
gdzie w każdym przypadku tensorujemy macierz unitarną z macierzą identyczności na każdym innym qubicie. Możemy więc wyrazić U_k —
czyli U zastosowane do qubitu K — jako tę samą kombinację liniową co poprzednio, z tym że każda macierz Pauliego jest stosowana do qubitu K.
Nie musimy zawracać sobie głowy indeksem dolnym dla identyczności — rozumiemy tu, że jest to identyczność na wszystkich
qubitach. Załóżmy teraz, że S jest 9-qubitowym kodowaniem stanu qubitu. Jeśli błąd U zachodzi na
qubicie K, dostajemy U_K * S, które możemy wyrazić jako kombinację liniową operacji Pauliego działających na S — co
oczywiście jest po prostu S w przypadku identyczności. W tym momencie pomocne będzie zaobserwowanie, że macierz Pauliego Y
jest równa iXZ, więc możemy dokonać tego podstawienia w naszym
wyrażeniu. Ten błąd więc nastąpił i teraz załóżmy, że próbujemy go skorygować za pomocą tej samej procedury co
poprzednio. Pierwszym krokiem jest obliczenie syndromu, który w przypadku kodu Shore'a ma 8 bitów — dwa bity dla każdego z
trzech razy, gdy używamy kodu wewnętrznego, plus dodatkowe dwa bity dla kodu zewnętrznego. Ale tak naprawdę nie ma to znaczenia — możemy po prostu
myśleć o nim jako o łańcuchu o stałej długości. Oto opis stanu, który dostajemy tuż przed pomiarem syndromu, gdzie każdy
syndrom jest tymi ośmioma bitami, które dostajemy z odpowiedniego błędu Pauliego. Zauważ w tym momencie, że dwa
układy są w ogólności splecione — i to jest naprawdę klucz do tego, żeby to wszystko działało. Przez zmierzenie syndromu, co
faktycznie zrobimy, jest zwinięcie stanu w taki, gdzie jedna z czterech operacji Pauliego została zastosowana do K-tego
qubitu w S i będziemy wiedzieć z syndromu, która operacja Pauliego to była. Możemy ją więc skorygować, jeśli
potrzeba. W szczególności, jeśli zmierzymy syndrom i dokonamy odpowiedniej korekcji, dostajemy stan
w formie pokazanej na ekranie, który krytycznie jest stanem produktowym. Mamy nasze oryginalne nieuszkodzone kodowanie jako
prawy czynnik tensorowy — co jest tu najważniejsze — a po lewej mamy macierz gęstości s, która
opisuje losowy syndrom błędu, ale nie ma już żadnej korelacji z układem, na którym nam zależy — tym
po prawej — bo błędy zostały skorygowane. Na tym etapie możemy wyrzucić qubity syndromu lub je zresetować,
jeśli chcemy ich użyć ponownie — i to jest właściwie dość ważne, bo właśnie w ten sposób losowość lub entropia
generowana przez błędy jest usuwana z układu. I tak właśnie działa dyskretyzacja błędów — przynajmniej dla unitarnych
błędów. W istocie przez zmierzenie syndromu efektywnie rzutujemy błąd na błąd opisywany przez
macierz Pauliego. Na pierwszy rzut oka może się wydawać zbyt dobrym, żeby być prawdziwym, że możemy korygować dowolne unitarne błędy
w ten sposób — nawet błędy, które są małe i ledwo zauważalne same w sobie. Ale ważne jest, żeby zdać sobie sprawę, że
jest to unitarny błąd na jednym qubicie i przez projekt kodu operacja na jednym qubicie nie może zmienić stanu
logicznego qubitu, który jest kodowany. Wszystko co może zrobić, to przenieść stan poza przestrzeń prawidłowych
kodowań, ale wtedy korekcje przywracają go dokładnie tam, gdzie był. Na koniec rozważmy, co się dzieje,
gdy zachodzi dowolny — niekoniecznie unitarny — błąd. Konfiguracja jest taka sama jak poprzednio —
zakodowaliśmy jeden qubit w 9 za pomocą kodu Shore'a i dowolny błąd reprezentowany przez kanał qubitowy Phi
zachodzi na jednym z qubitów. Jak zobaczymy, wszystko będzie działać mniej więcej tak samo
jak dla unitarnych błędów. Pierwszym krokiem ku weryfikacji tego jest rozważenie reprezentacji Kraussa naszego
błędu. Możemy teraz postępować dokładnie tak samo jak dla unitarnych błędów, z tym że stosujemy to rozumowanie
do macierzy Kraussa, a nie do jednej unitarnej macierzy reprezentującej błąd.
W szczególności każda macierz Kraussa może być wyrażona jako kombinacja liniowa macierzy Pauliego i pozwala nam to
wyrazić działanie tego błędu Phi na dowolny qubit K, na który działa, w formie pokazanej tutaj na
ekranie. Wszystko co tu robimy, to rozwijanie macierzy Kraussa jako kombinacji liniowych macierzy Pauliego. Jeśli następnie
obliczamy i mierzymy syndrom błędu i korygujemy wszelkie błędy, które zostają ujawnione, dostaniemy podobny rodzaj
stanu do tego, co mieliśmy w przypadku unitarnego błędu. Nie będę omawiać szczegółów — są one bardzo podobne do unitarnego
przypadku i też trochę bardziej bałaganliwe do zapisania, ale konceptualnie jest to dość
proste. Powinienem wspomnieć, że to wszystko uogólnia się na inne kwantowe kody korekcji błędów, w tym kody, które mogą korygować błędy na wielu
qubitach. W takim przypadku błędy na wielu qubitach można wyrazić jako kombinacje liniowe tensorowych iloczynów macierzy Pauliego
i odpowiednio różne możliwe syndromem opisują korekcje wykonywane na wielu qubitach, a nie tylko na jednym.
Ale podstawowa idea jest dokładnie taka sama. Ponownie przez zmierzenie syndromu
efektywnie rzutujemy lub zwijamy błędy na dyskretny zestaw możliwości reprezentowanych przez tensorowe iloczyny
macierzy Pauliego. I przez skorygowanie tych błędów — czyli błędów Pauliego — możemy odzyskać oryginalny
zakodowany stan. Tymczasem wszelka losowość generowana w tym procesie jest przenoszona do qubitów syndromu, które możemy następnie
wyrzucić lub zresetować — co jest kluczowe, bo właśnie w ten sposób entropia generowana przez błędy i pomiary syndromu jest
usuwana z układu. I to jest koniec lekcji, w której po raz pierwszy przyjrzeliśmy się
kwantowej korekcji błędów, w tym 9-qubitowemu kodowi Shore'a i dyskretyzacji błędów. Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie w
następnej lekcji, w której omówimy formalizm stabilizatorów, który dostarcza nam potężnego narzędzia do opisywania i
analizowania dużej i ciekawej klasy kwantowych kodów korekcji błędów, w tym takich, które są obiecującymi kandydatami dla
prawdziwych komputerów kwantowych. Do zobaczenia.